[Music]
alisa joins us now in denver colorado
lisa how can we help
hello ken i was originally calling for
you
but if i think seriously about it i
think it might be a deloney question oh
i promise you it's a combo whether you
wanted it to be or not
so i have a job opportunity and
it's the same job i do now
um which is what it is
i i'm in sales i sell science and
graphics kim actually called your show
two months ago you told me to take the
job it was a different job take the job
but it wasn't a money move so i didn't
do it my boss gave me more money
now i have another opportunity for even
more money
seventeen thousand dollars more
just on the base salary the commission
structure is another
uh six percent better than my current
job on paper it is the right thing to do
the the healthcare package is better the
401k package is better i mean everything
is better
um
i ghosted this company who pursued me
back in july i i guess i didn't show up
to an interview and then he reached back
out conversations are going again
um
he thinks i'm i'm the right fit even
even though i showed to be a terrible
employee during the interview process
i am so apprehensive i cannot pull the
trigger i cannot make the decision
so that's where john delaney comes in
well before we get to john i want to go
and pull this thing apart well no
we're going to we're going to work on
this together but i do want to go back
to the you said you called my show two
months ago and i told you to take
another job which means leave where you
are now why did i tell you that i don't
remember the call give me the quick
version sure yeah so it was it's the
same
before it was the same exact job for the
same exact company but it's a franchise
it would have been a different location
it wasn't a money move
um
there
ultimately i mean the issue at my at my
place of employment you know i want i
wanted to own one of these franchises
one day and the
i was
when i was hired it was understood that
they would train me and mentor me
throughout the process to become a
franchisee right and they
so i'm just trying to get caught up
really quick and so i told you take this
other opportunity where there's a ladder
is that about right
that is correct because that's what i
would tell anybody who called in okay
great
okay and so yes let's get to the
apprehensive stuff um
what are you so afraid of
name it specifically
so specifically this job is set up
different everything is done third party
i'm more like a graphics broker and less
and less like a sign like where i work
now we make everything in-house we work
directly with the customer what i'll be
working directly with the customer but
i'll be giving what are you scared of
lisa what are you scared of you sound
like a politician like at a press
conference i didn't get a straight
answer elisa tell us
what are you so afraid of
well one i'll be working from home and
i'm terrified of that i don't think i
have the discipline to work from home
great that's one thing what's another
thing you're afraid of
um i am also the sole breadwinner my
husband is a stay-at-home parent
and i'm afraid the ramp-up period where
i start making commission will be too
great and going into the winter seasons
and christmas time
if i was on baby step three i would do
this in a second but i'm not i'm on baby
step two and i'm scared to make the move
now i feel like i'm jumping from the
ship to the dock instead of just
stepping over
and
but it's the same exact job
yeah yeah
yeah but i thought you said that you
there was 17 grand thought the 17 grand
was already there that didn't even count
the uh take account for the commission
yeah that's yeah that's just a base
dollar it's 57 000 a year
i make 80 now so i mean if assuming that
i don't sell anything for a year then
really it's a 23 000 pick cut i know
that i'm not going to sell anything for
a year i'm going to sell stuff but
but you know the first few months
okay so so hurry so let's stay right
there let's okay that's the monster
under the bed
right okay other than the stay at home
and i think john i'd like john to speak
to that because i think there's some
stuff there i think you got to listen to
that because i tell you right now i
could not work from home no i just i
couldn't but let's talk about the
financial piece let john tackle the
other
the financial piece is okay what would
need to be true for the first two or
three months that we would need to cut
back on you know where would we cut how
would we adjust our budget what would we
do differently just to pad that to where
you're not in a desperate situation
you're just in a hustle situation
there's a big difference there you
understand what i'm saying
yeah but i'm in a desperate situation
like my
i went and got a different bank account
the other day because my other bank
account was
1500 overdrawn and i didn't want my
direct deposit to go somewhere i mean i
am in a desperate okay well that's
breaking news to john and i so that
would have been nice with that one
well that's new and i mean and i've
never
the money stuff i've never dealt with
the money situation that i've dealt with
now i used to i paid off forty thousand
dollars in debt and then all of a sudden
i'm just like screwing up royally
hold so i i actually wrote down here
monster
this has nothing to do with your job no
you're a woman who's scared to death
yes and
you are on a ship that you think is
sinking and you are looking for the
first place to jump off of and right
before you jump every time
whether it's your husband
your whatever
someone's holding you by the sock and
you're not jumping
but you got something going on at your
house that you're not safe or you're not
okay or something's not right
because you're i'm an alcoholic and i
have a gambling edition here we go
yeah yeah i mean i i'm i'm totally fine
with
admitting to those things and and i've
been praying about it and i've been
working on it and all of it is getting
better
but i don't know if all of you
listen better before i take the job at
least it's not getting better you you're
in the whole fifteen hundred dollars
you're now you're now opening up new
checking accounts to go under in
you got a husband that's at home that's
not working
you're in a desperate mess
yeah so i'm gonna tell you something
right now he he needs to get a job he
has to
yeah but y'all wouldn't i'm i'm fine
with getting a second job i did that for
a little while okay so my dad died i had
two cars stolen you need to get a second
job you get a job but you wouldn't you
wouldn't say that to a stay-at-home mom
i absolutely would yeah i would too i
absolutely would wrong answer
i don't know i mean i hear dave say all
the time like oh i love it when moms can
stay home but you can't but he can't
stay home you guys are drowning alisa
here's what i'm hearing i'm hearing an
addict and i'm hearing an addict who's
great at going to war
i'm not gonna fight you ken's not gonna
fight you
you need help
you don't need a new job
yeah definitely you need money and you
need help your husband needs to get a
job you've got to get clean
and you got to
have a season of peace
asap last thing you need is the stress
coming with a straight commission or a
heavy commission job stay where you are
a second job will keep you busy make
some more money hubs has got to get out
to work and you guys got to get help
you can do this though you've done it
before you can do it again this is the
ramsay show